meanwhile what's next in Home
Improvement this morning we're getting a
first look inside at World Market Center
that's right because this week is the
Winter Market it's an array of furniture
and Home Decor all things that make you
really excited once you hit like 30.
that's the furniture cut off is Charles
joining us live at World Market Center
this morning uh I'm excited about this
Candace you've seen you've showed us
some really cool things this morning
well Heather I'm not going to age myself
but I like Furniture it's fun it's
exciting so but also you know I'm
looking for pieces like this right now
I'm in hooker Furnishings showroom it's
one of really hundreds that are here a
lot of exhibitors coming down people
from all over the world really coming to
see what items they're going to be
putting on that display for themselves
you guys will be able to see them
shortly but we're giving you a sneak
peek today you can't be that and of
course I'm joined by Alexandra O'Hara
thank you so much for joining us this
morning now something you said that's
been interesting is you're seeing a lot
more traffic we've been to this market
for about three times three three years
so you're starting to see a lot more
people why is that you think I think
that everyone's ready to get back out
there you know following the the
lockdown we all experienced during covet
and and really being Homebound and not
able to hit the road
um you know everybody's got the urge to
to get out there and Shop which is great
well that means we're going to start to
see a lot more options in a lot of
different places is including here right
so tell us a little bit about some of
her Furnishings Trends going on right
now absolutely
um I think that we've all seen an
affinity back towards brown furniture
you know we we saw the cool tones and
Grays is the classic right watch white
washed Furniture over the course of the
last three or four years and we have
seen that brown is absolutely back which
which we love and obviously have tried
to leverage here in our space in Las
Vegas now tell us a little bit about
where else people can see some of the
furniture absolutely so we are
distributed you know all over the world
we have fabulous Retail Partners
Nationwide and and globally but we're
also available through interior
designers and with select Partners
online as well and many of those you'll
meet this week right absolutely and
hopefully some new ones as well awesome
well good luck to you guys out here have
a great time it sounds like it's going
to be amazing and the furniture is
really absolutely beautiful thank you so
much Candace and of course you guys can
find out more details about her
furnishings and all the things that are
going on at the market on our website
itnewsnow.com guys all right Candace
thank you very much brown furniture huh
is it 1976 again